يعني مثلا خلينا نقول في انواع بتعطيك
ونجرام بيعطيك اربع كالوريس وبالتالي تحسب
على حسب سعرات الحراريه بحيث انها ما تزيد
وفينا بتعطيك 0 سعرات حراريه ولكن المسموح
فيها اذا زاد يعني مثلا خلينا نقول نفس
الارستو اللي محطوط في هو سكر هو
كربوهيدرات ومن سكريات الكحوليه اللي
موجوده صفر كالوريز ما فيها سعرات ولكن 75
غرام لكل كيلو جرام بالوزن وان غرام فعلى
حسب وزن اذا زاد عن ذلك
يتخزن على هيئه الدهون يؤدي الى مشاكل
اخرى وبالتالي ايضا خليني اقول معلومه انه
معظم المحليات تدخل على الجسم ما بيتم
هضمها ولا امتصاصها بتروح على القولون على
طول تتخمر في القولون وبالتالي
دخلنا في قصص نفخه
القولون غازات اسهال لها علاقه بالماده
اللي هيك قرانا عنها
هو نوع من انواع المحليات على فكره
وكان لفتره كان عليه كتير قصص ولكن الاف
دي اي ومنظمه الصحه العالميه
اذا نعم اذا تم تناوله
بالكميات اللي لازمه حتى تنفيذ المشاهدين
دكتوره انا رحت للسوبر ماركت على شو لازم
ادقق قبل ما اشتري شيء اول شيء خليني احكي
معلومه انه الكالوري اذا كالوري سعره
الحراريه كان دراسه جديده
كندا تمت الان بمؤتمر القلبيه من اسبوعين
تقريبا وتم نشر دراسه الف شخص انه اذا
السعر الحريه هي سعره حراريه يجب ان تحسب
وبالتالي هي تدخل الجسم
وكيفيه حرقها هو هو المفيد اذا انا اكون
نشيط اتناول معدل السعرات الحراريه حسب
البيزل تبعي حسب معدل الايض وبالتالي انا
بطمن اني انا ما بصير عندي مشاكل هاي واحد
اثنين اقرا اذا شو قالت لي هل هو فات فري
وهذا اللي حضرتك تفضلتي فيه اول شيء انه
نقاده مين قال انه ما في فات هو ايضا
بيزيد الوزن وبالتالي ممكن يتخزن اذا في
كتير مشاكل انا في غنى عنها كل المحليات
يجب ان اخذها المراه مسموح لها خلينا نقول
بحدود 40 غرام والرجل 45 جرام يعني بحدود
معلقه تقريبا